so thank you for the organizer for
inviting me and giving me this great
opportunity to talk here I'm very happy
to be here so today I will present some
work I've done an information extraction
but I also try to present some kind of
where is the field right now and what
are the big challenge is about
information extraction so very briefly
what's information extraction so the
goal is to extract structural
information from an structured documents
so for example to build the knowledge
base from free text or text in human
language and so one of the obvious
motivation for this kind of information
extraction is to be able to answer to
that kind of query and so to be able to
know that the population of Los Angeles
for example is a bit less of 4 million
people and it's in the US and all old
all do stuff and so no I'll give some
some example of some specific example of
information extraction so the first one
is just to extract named entities such
as the name of off location of or the
name of a person from from human
language text and so traditionally in
NLP people have been trying to have been
working on datasets which focused on
three kind of named entities which are
people location and organization but
depending on what domain you walking in
those named entities can be a lot of
different things such as genes cell's
proteins if you're working in the
biomedical domains laptops men of
laptops phones camera if you trying to
extract those kind of
things I don't know from Twitter or
whatever so second important things to
do is to be able to once you've
extracted those those entities to link
them into a knowledge base for example
and because a lot of those entities are
very ambiguous for example Michael
Jordan so of course is the fat the very
famous basketball player but she's also
a very famous professor of machine
learning at UC Berkeley and you don't
want to miss take those two person when
you extracting information about them
and so finally you'd like to be able to
extract relations between those dues
named entities so for example in that
sentence he in that sentence you have a
bunch of entities again and so the kind
operation that you'd like to extract is
the fact that Alan Turing was an
employee of the government code and
cypher school or the fact that the
school was located at Bletchley Park and
most state-of-the-art method for for
information extraction are based on
supervised machine learning and showed
in the last 15 years there's there's
been a lot of advance in information
extraction things to these to these
techniques but they still suffer from a
I think quite limitations the first one
is obviously the fact that you need
level data which is often quite
expensive to obtain and in information
extraction this is really a problem
because you have really thousand
different kind of entities or relations
that should like to extract and you
can't reasonably label the data for all
those kind of entities or relations the
second thing is that if you want to
develop for example a product and you'd
like to make this product available for
different languages you don't want to
annotate data for each new language its
new language you want to support
another limitation is the fact that it's
not robust at all to the main shift and
so this is an example of a sentence that
extracted from a financial report about
a healthcare company and so Henry Schein
is actually an l square company and so
given the fact that it appears in that
particular document it's much more
likely that this is this is referring to
the company than to a person but a named
entity extraction system trained on
general data we will always level this
as a person and actually it makes sense
I mean without knowing that this
sentence is extracted from a financial
report most most of you would say that
only shrine is a curio person so no I
will present to of so 2 of in more
detail two of these for EM so the first
one is is the relation extraction and so
one of the things people have been
working on to not rely on level data is
to actually use an existing knowledge
base instead of level data so for
example you can consider this very
simple knowledge base with two to two
facts to named entities and so then you
can extract named entities from
unlabeled data link them to do that to
the knowledge base and then labelled
each of this sentence using the relation
that appear in your knowledge base so of
course the problem with that approach is
that the labelled data that you obtain
is very noisy because a lot of the named
entity pairs we can verify for example
several relation so you have to be able
to say which one which sentence express
the fact that Eastern Stein was born in
New York City and which one
express the fact that Eastern Stein died
in New York City another thing is the
fact that many of those sentence
actually does not express any relation
you are interested in and so you don't
want to label those sentences as
expressing one of the relation and so
when one of the the solution for these
primates to view this this as a multiple
instance multiple ad level learning cram
so multiple instance because for each
entity pair you'll have a lot of
sentences so those are your multiple
instances and for each again for each
pair of entities you want to be able to
predict a lot of different relation and
so some very quick notation so for the
rest of the this this part xn will be a
vector a feature vector that will
represent each sentence so and so we
have we suppose that we have k different
duration and so the we have a matrix F
ik that will tell us if the entity pair
I verify this duration k so basically
this is the information that is in the
knowledge base and we have a second
matrix e such that II I n is equal to
one if the sentence n and in particular
the pair of entities apparent sentence n
is linked to the pair of entity I and so
basically this is the information the
data linking the linking part the entity
linking part and so what I will present
no is a way to infer for each sentences
the
actual operation that is Express in that
in that sentence and so once you have
been able to infer this level you can
just train a regular classifier because
you have in that case regular level data
and so the goal is to infer matrix Y
such that y NK is equal to one if the
sentence n express the relation k and
the zero otherwise and so the approach i
will describe is based on discriminative
constrain that i will know rapidly
introduced so the idea of discriminative
clustering is let's say that we have a
set of that event and you would like to
cluster them into two groups and so the
criterion that will be used to say that
a clustering is a good one if is there
exists a good classifier separating
these two group of point and so
basically what what discriminative
clustering is trying to find is a set so
two groups of points that can be very
easily predicting using discriminative
algorithms such as an SVM or a logistic
regression so basically this means that
if you have a lost function L such as
the inverse or do logistic loss and a
given a regularizer Omega the goal is to
find a matrix Y and a classifier f
minimizing the empirical risk and so the
good thing about this approach is that
we can very easily put the information
we know about our data by putting some
some constraint into y and so basically
what will do is that will use the
supervision obtained thanks to the
knowledge base by defining some
constraint on why so the first the first
constraint is that we suppose that each
sentence express exactly one
one operation and so basically what what
does that mean it means that the the
line and the line of the matrix why
there should be exactly 11 and so we
could rewrite this as because why is it
by binary matrix as the fact that the
sum of the other line should sum to 1
the second constraint is the fact that
if I cut again according to the
knowledge base an entity / I verify
verify the relation k then we suppose
that we have at least one sentence in
our data set that will express that fact
and so basically what does that mean so
I remind you that II I n is equal to one
if the sentence n corresponds to the
entity pair I so this me this means that
for all those for all the sentence in
which the entity pair I appear so
basically for all the sentence and such
that II I n is equal to one we want at
least one of the corresponding Y and k
to be equal to 1 and so basically again
we can write this as taking the sum over
all the sentence that in which the
entity pair I appears and taking the sum
over all those sentence we want these
sums to be greater than one and so we
can rewrite this like that and so we are
we obtain a linear constraint on the
matrix value on the other hand if an
entity pair I does not verify a relation
k then we suppose that no sentences in
our data set express that that
desperation so basically that's that's
kind of a strong constraint because it's
suppose that the the knowledge base is
actually complete that there is no
missing
information in the knowledge base which
of course is not really true but that's
not that big of a deal because first
foremost relations this is actually true
and if and and you could actually only
consider when building a data set the
named entities that you you think that
you have most of the information for
example named entities that are very
common such as Barack Obama I mean the
for example the children of Barack Obama
obviously all all in the in already in
in the in the knowledge base and so
there's no missing information in that
case and so again we will consider
exactly the same kind of constraints so
it's except that in that case instead of
forcing the sun to be at least you got
one we want all the elements of that
some to be equal to zero and so this is
equivalent to saying that the sun should
actually be equal to 0 so this is very
similar to the to the to the previous
constraint and so finally a small
technical constraint we suppose we don't
want to put too much to classify too
much too many sentences as the non
relation and so we just impose that at
most a certain percentage of of deus
will be classified as as author or none
and so again can write this as a linear
constraint and under matrix Y and so
this constraint can be rewrite it in
that way and no I'll so first is there
any questions so far the ok this one
that one okay so basically the first one
is just saying that all the all the the
sum of all the line is equal to one and
the second one is just rewriting the
three other constraints by introducing
two matrix 1 much weeks s but this is
not really important any other questions
okay so no I will go back to the
discriminative formulation of the
problem and so in in that case we'll use
the first linear classifiers and the
square loss so the square us is not a
classification loss so that's a bit
strange to use that loss instead of the
in july's of the logistic class and so
the the the reason for that is the fact
that that that that formulation is
actually this loss function is actually
jointly convex in y and w so this
problem and and we can obtain a closed
form solution for the value but so in
this forum everything is context instead
except for the constraint that why
should be a boolean matrix and so
replacing the value by its optimal value
we obtain a problem that is a quadratic
integral program and so this is in
general this is a np-hard this is an NPR
program but again there's only this this
this constraint that'sthat's non convex
and so the very natural things to do
seem to do is just to relax this
constraint into the fact that the the
wise should
into the between zero and one and in
that case we obtain a convex quadratic
program which is which can be solved by
any solver of such as mosaic or anything
and it's actually very easy to very easy
to solve the other interesting thing
about that formulation is the fact that
it only depends on the kernel matrix X X
transpose and so basically instead of
taking linear classifier you could use
any you could replace you could use any
kernel that that you want and actually
in the field of relation extraction a
bunch of kernel based on dependency
trees has been used and so that would be
it would be possible to to use this kind
of colonel in that case so
so why are the other latent variables
yeah and X corresponds to the vector
that will describe each one of your
sentence and so basically you trying to
predict Y using just regular dot product
between the value and X yeah okay so of
course since we've relaxed the forum the
solution will obtain is not an integral
solution and so one solution to obtain a
an integer solution is actually to
project the the to take the orthogonal
projection of the matrix Y star the
optimal solution of the relax problem
unto the set of indicator matrices so in
that case when when doing this kind this
kind of running you don't necessarily
obtain a solution of that that will
verify the the original constraints but
in practice it's it works it works
really really well but there's no
guarantee that the solution obtained in
that way verifies the the the original
constraints and so using this way you
can then just train a regular multi
class classifier to learn to extract
correction so very quick word about
optimization so in that case it's
actually easier to solve the jewel that
the primal problem because in the primal
problem you have this matrix inverse
which is kind of a problem because if
you have millions
of example this this matrix X X
transpose plus lambda I n is actually a
million times a million so it's a very
large matrix and it's not necessarily
easy to compute its its inverse but
actually in the individual you you get
rid of this disinvest and the moreover
the constraints are much much simpler
and so it's very easy to project under
under constraint and so it's possible to
use an accelerated projected gradient
descent algorithm sometimes refer to as
vista and so the overall complexity of
the this optimization algorithm is 0 of
1 iteration of this algorithm is 0 of n
FK where air n is the number of
sentences f is the number the average
number of feature used to describe a
sentence and k is the number of classes
so now i'll briefly present some
experiments so the experiments were
carried out on the data set made of
article from the New York Times so the
entities were extracted using another
shelf named entities recognizer and they
were linked to freebase within using a
very simple heuristic that just a string
match thought there was actually quite a
noise coming from there and so there's
52 relations 4030 pairs and 100,000
sentences so n is equal to 127 in that
case and so as I the feature built as
follow so we consider lexical features
that such as the sequence of war between
the 28th is the word that will appear
before
first entity and after the second entity
the part of speech of this world we also
consider a syntactic features such as
the dependency pass the pass in the
dependency tree between the two entities
or the neighbor of each entity into the
dependency tree and so when one of the
first so here is results and comparison
to other methods so the first one is the
the things I described at the beginning
of the talk is just to arista khalil a
bell each sentence using all the the
door labels that you can get into into
you your knowledge base so of course
there's there's a lot of noise but still
it's it's quite it is working it's
working a bit in practice then the these
are two methods bed based on latent
variable model and which actually are
not convex and kind of suffer from from
the initialization you are using and so
here is the method I've just described
and so obviously it would be interesting
to try to initialize the previous model
using the the method i have described
which i haven't done yet and so here is
here are the result for different kind
of operations to show you that it's
working quite well for sent certain kind
of relation such as the fact that
location contains another location or
the fact that a person is working for a
company but it's not working very well
for all that kind of variations such as
the the fact that somebody was born in a
certain place or the fact that a person
I've lived in a place and I think that's
just because this and
decent Chinese actually not present in
to the new york times article and so
finally here other the result for
classifying at the sentence Ravel so
that's that's the for each sentence
saying which variation is expressed by
the sentence while the previous results
where for each entity pair saying which
of the relation that are verified by a
by that that entity bar so any question
on that yes yes
that's a good question and I don't know
because I haven't really tried to to see
what happens when you're so basically I
cross-validated this C parameter but I
don't know what happens for example when
you go from a complete you know for
example if you entity up here then you
don't have any information about those
entities in your database and so maybe
you'd see wouldn't be the same and some
kinds of things like that so I I don't
know any other question okay so no i'll
talk about named entity classification
and a particular poem which is
extracting named entities from technical
texts such as financial reports and so I
think that those the current state of
the art is not really a good way to
address this program first because again
for most of the technical domain you
don't have a label data so gone because
there's this domain shift and so even if
you you just want to extract for example
the name of organization from financial
reports the something system trained on
general context from general domain is
doing actually very poorly on on
technical technical text and actually
there's one more interesting thing is
that for many domains this named
entities are actually not only use at
all and so you don't need to have
something as a classifier that is as
fancy as the thing that are currently
the state of the app because
since the the named entities menu named
entities are not only used the firm is
much much easier than for general domain
and so another an old idea for training
and named entity extraction system with
that level data is to start from a seed
list so for example a small list of
companies and to try to match those
named entity to unlevel text and then to
obtain some kind of labelled example so
that you can extract for example pattern
that will allow you to extract new named
entity from your unlevel text and then
you can iterate this this process to
grow the set of named entities and grow
the set of pattern and in the end be
able to learn to extract most most of
these dis named entities
yeah but that's that's really maybe
that's not a very good example but yeah
that's that's for extracting named
entities and so for example one other
pattern could be the fact that you will
have the the token Inc after the after
the name of of companies yeah exactly
and so when one of the limitation with
this scheme is the fact that you can
rapidly have a lot of noise into your
list of of named entities and once you
starting to make some small mistake into
the the entities you're extracting very
rapidly this current this can go
completely out of out of control and
you'll end up with extracting something
really different than what what you
intended so here what I propose is do
something slightly difference is again
to start in the same way so with a list
of named entities we extract to try so
to match all those all those all the
elements of the seed list into unlevel
text to obtain a positive example and
because again we assume that the named
entities are not only use these dues are
really positive in Perl and then you can
try to train a classifier using those
positive example you've extracted and
but you do not you will not iterate
between extracting the entities training
your classifier extracting more entities
you really want to train the classifier
at once and so but the problem in that
case is that you don't have
negative example you only have positive
example the thing that you've been able
to match into your to something that
appear on you see list and all the other
potential named entities are actually
unlabeled example and so this is an
example of something that's referred to
PU running in the machine learning
community which is learning from
positive and unlabeled example only and
so no basically I'll show that this this
program of learning from positive and
unlabeled example is very similar to
what I've presented in the first part of
the talk and the same kind of tool can
can can be used so again a very quick
notation so the vector X in that case
are a set of feature that will describe
each potential named entity and so the
text surrounding this this potential
named entity so please the set of
positive example you is the set of
unlabeled example and so we suppose that
we have a bunch of labelled for the
positive example and again we allowed we
have a labelled order for all the things
that are not actually named entities
again the goal will be to infer binary
matrix Y and K such that y NK is equal
to one if the mention the potential
named entity mention n is actually of
class K and 0 otherwise and so basically
what change to the pledges for M is the
kind of constraints that will will put
an unwise so again we suppose that each
named entity belongs to only one class
so that's the the equivalent of the fact
that each sentence can express only one
oration so again why should some
one and the line of course for the
positive example we want the matrix Y to
agree to what we've obtained using the
seediest so y of n CN should be equal to
1 and so finally since we don't want all
the all the example to be classified as
one of our potential class will impose
that we have at least a certain
percentage of the example to be
classified as other and so again we'll
have a parameter of key in that case
saying okay i want i want i don't know
maybe fifty percent of my potential
named entity to be classified as as as
other so other any question and those
constraints i guess it really depends on
the data set your concern so again we
can formulate this using in our
classifier and the square laws and we
obtain a problem that's very similar to
the previous one except that the consu
the constraints on why are a bit
different but again there's still linear
constraints so we still obtain a
quadratic integer integer havana and
again we'll relax the fact that the
matrix why should be a bit binary matrix
into the fact that why should be the
wise should be between between 0 and 1
and we obtain a plan that again is
jointly convex in y and w and so can be
easily solved with any of the Shelf
quadratic solver so this is pretty much
work in progress so the data set are
considered for for this this problem is
a bit of a toy that i said so the goal
is to extract name
of companies and name of drugs from
financial reports corresponding to a
healthcare company so as the deed list
we've considered the name of publicly
traded companies the 200 must search
drags on the website on a website
listing all the drunk the drugs that are
sold in the in the US and as feature so
we used the tokens that appear in the in
the entity mention the word that
appeared before and after the again the
DNC store in the dependency tree and the
vectorial representation of dimension
award embedding of dimension and so here
are the result so the the first one the
distant third enya is a state-of-the-art
named entity recognizer system that was
trained on general domain and so what
what we see is the recall for that
system is a very very low induce induce
that I said because for example as pen
is will always be classified as a
location or mark is easy and classified
as a person and things like that the
second one is the string match to show
you actually the the in that case the
named entities are I really not only use
and so we we have a precision that are
almost one hundred one hundred percent
and that the record is actually not that
bad I was quite surprised that that it
was so so high and so the the last one
the SVM so is just training an estimate
an SVM with a symmetric cost for the
positive example and the end labelled
example which is something that's worked
quite well for
for pure running and so finally the
method that I've presented which
obtained results which are very similar
to the asymmetric svm and so here are
the the some curve to show the influence
of the parameter of P so when the
perimeter of P increase will attend to
classify more and more potential named
entities as other and so the recoil will
drop but the precision will will augment
and so that's that's why that's what you
can observe here and so actually that's
a way to choose the the press finds the
precision or the recoil of your of your
class fare so the yeah this is P against
the procedure on the record and and the
f1 score of the the the classifier so do
you have any question yes
that's a good question actually so
actually the for this experiments the
there there's only one classifier that
is trained the multi class classifier is
trained and so the piece does the same
for the two for the two classes and why
um does the the the effect is different
i I don't I don't know yeah yeah that's
that's that that can be a return another
reason could be the fact that one class
is more frequent than the other another
reason could be the fact that drugs may
be appearing simple simple patterns to
extract and I haven't really tried to
know what why it was different but
actually yet though the good thing is
the optimal p is almost the same for the
for the two classes and actually it it
almost correspond to the actual
percentage of a man mention that should
be classified as other so that means
that you could actually set if you know
the percentage of named entities that a
does other you you can set P that way at
least under that notice a yes
so you yeah so you either need a test
set or again you can also just try to
know the percentage of things that's
classified as other but which is
actually much easier to obtain that that
labid data because you can just take
maybe a couple of sentences and just
roughly compute how many of your example
as are actually order and you don't have
to label each of the the positive
example into one class or even have one
example for each of those positive class
so that's easier and if you want of
course if you want to cause validate p
then you need level data so to conclude
so I presented the method for learning
to extract information using distance
supervision which is based on a
discriminative clustering so that's that
leads to a convex from formulation
that's quite easy to solve in practice
and it seems to be quite competitive to
other techniques to other techniques for
information extraction in the distance
distantly supervised setting again this
is pretty much work in progress and so
there's some different things that I am
working on or back to work on the first
one is to develop faster optimization
method for this approach because this
couldn't scales for right now to
millions or tens of millions of example
or two millions or to earth thousands of
operation the second one which is quite
related to the first one is how to
canalize deuce method in practice
because
when for kernel methods you have this
giant kernel matrix to compute to
compute which is actually n by n where n
n is the number of example and so in
that case it's not trivial to do and so
finally I'd like to consider or
challenging data set for the named
entity classify classification task and
in particular data set in which the
named entity are ambiguous because it's
possible using the same framework to
consider such such entities so if you
are interested in more details there's
those two paper that described the thing
there's code on my web page but that's
research card so it's very specific to
the data sets and everything that's
described and induce article so it's not
really usable in practice and I might
try to release a general code for that
that Prime in the future and thank you
for your attention being here and
inviting me
okay in any questions left we have one
question microphone you compared several
different methods is it possible to
generalize it and say what the
computational complexity is a number of
operations or some other way to talk
about the different methods and you had
a feeling for the it's called speed
accuracy trade-off so which methods
actually okay so for example so the
first one so it's just training a multi
class classifier the orange one so
that's super fast and that actually kind
of the fastest thing you can do and so
then in the two other method so there's
one that's really fast because they're
relying on approximation tricks and so
it's it's actually almost as fast as the
soft one while the other one is a pretty
complicated latent variable model where
the inference is complicated and and so
it's actually slower than a slightly
slower than the the method i presented I
don't know if that's that answer your
question oh so and so on for example
induce and this data set so again for
fifty relations and 100,000 example I
think that the the the the very naive
method is something like of the order of
a minute or couple of minutes the fast
latent variable model is also like maybe
10 minutes the other end the 201 is your
Oh else any other questions
and we have any general insights on how
to deal with the problem that you need a
test set for evaluation I know so the so
actually so how this is this is a good
question oh this is evaluated so this is
actually evaluated on three bays and so
this is not the actually precision and
recall of this method because freebase
is incomplete and so you'll actually
extract the fact that are not in feed as
yet and so when you evaluate you'll say
oh this does not apparent freebase so
this is a false positive and actually
the famous I I don't think that there's
a good way to to evaluate when you want
to to train to such method and large
number of relations because you cannot
so you can either labelled data for
subsample of relation or rely on
something like using an existing
knowledge base or does another there's a
way to evaluate the precision of Jacques
failure by by taking for example the
couple hundred of thousand of extraction
and actually say if it's a correct
extraction or not but you cannot
evaluate the recoil that way so there's
no I think there's no good way to to
evaluate you also gift like a sentence
level yes didn't recall so that you also
use do that only using freebase or how
do you do that so this was so a couple
of of sentences 1000 sentences I think
we're labelled we are handled and so we
just you just take the classifier that
you've just trained you run induced
sentences and then you can since you've
you have the lab l4h sentence you can
average
Lucas fail is the approach of in the
algorithm itself minimizing with respect
to both y and w is that dependent upon
these convex relaxations or can other
techniques use minimization of both so
once so that's lots of a half way to do
that the first one of the the one of the
thing that you could do is something
like em for example and so to alternate
between the optimization and y and on
undervalue and keeping the the the Y
integer integer you can also consider
other kind of convex relaxation more
complicated convex relaxation like SDP
relaxation and things like that which
usually give better results but in that
case that kind of complicated because of
the the constraints that that appear I
don't know any other techniques as
thank the speaker